[Music]
okay thank you for your time I said we
wanted to get a conversation going
between people in networking optics
hardware distributed systems and the
main motivation here is actually very
simple it's the fact that this is a time
of change if you look at almost any
resource online cloud infrastructure
whether it's compute networking inside
the data center or in the long haul or
different kinds of storage the dominant
technology for each of these resources
is approaching the tail end of its
s-curve things are looking like a
plateau for example if you think about
compute the primary metric of interest
is flops per dollar that begin achieve
thanks to Moore's law and they're not
scaling we've had a lovely ride over the
past 35 years but because of fundamental
physical constraints on the size of
transistors on the CPU drive voltage and
the number of cores that we can put on
individual sockets sin seeing things
seem to be flatline now this is actually
prompted a lot of work in custom
accelerators things like FPGAs and GPUs
and custom Asics
that are getting a lot of traction in
cloud environments and you probably
heard math talk about the growth of
FPGAs are later in this session you'll
hear from Tom and Sam Rama about some of
the FPGA innovation happening for
networking workloads similarly when you
start thinking about the network inside
datacenters it relies on electrical
switches and there's an analogous
phenomena that I'm terming the Moore's
law for networking essentially every
couple of years
switch renders give us a new switch
generation that has double the bandwidth
but the cost remains exactly the same
now this is a lovely property because it
allows us to build faster and faster
networks that can keep pace with
increasing demand while keeping the
overall network cost low and constant
that's actually one of the assumptions
underlying the cloud economic model
however things could start getting
tricky very soon and to understand that
let's look at this graph again
so historically the increase in switch
bandwidth has come from the fact that we
are able to increase the speed of the
services at the edge of the switching
ASIC and the switch wonders have always
used the non-return-to-zero modulation
format so one is encoded as high voltage
zero as low voltage however the latest
generation of switches is the first
generation where we've had to rely to
hire a resort to higher order modulation
because it's becoming harder and harder
to increase the speed and the density of
those i/o pins so this is like four
level modulation which means that you
encode two bits per symbol but it means
that you have tighter SNR requirements
because the levels are getting closer
and closer and this is a trick that's
hard to play over and over again because
if you go to eight levels your s on our
requirements are even harsher so if you
were to step back and look at network
inside datacenters the primary metric of
interest is the gigabits per dollar
we've had a lovely ride but within the
next five six years so by the time we
get to 50 terabytes which generation
beyond that things could start to look
very dodgy the same thing applies to
other resources if you look at van
capacity we are actually approaching the
Shannon capacity of individual fibers if
you go to the next storage session
you'll hear about fundamental physical
reasons why we are approaching capacity
limits on hard drives now if you are the
CTO of a company this is a nightmare
scenario you know it's a perfect strong
but for researchers this is the perfect
opportunity because it means that if we
you if we come up with the new
technology no matter how disruptive it
is if it leads to a new growth curve in
terms of these metrics of interest it
has a very good chance of deployment and
I think that's a really powerful message
and if that's the only message that you
take away from this talk or even from
this session at least I and Yibo will be
delighted so what I want to do next is
talk to you about a little bit about the
disruptions happening in the networking
space and tell you about
optical innovations that we're doing
inside the company both in research and
in Azure networking to address these
challenges so I'm gonna start with the
network inside the data centers and if
you remember I told you about this
Moore's Law for networking and the fact
that that has allowed us to keep the
cost of the network low and constant
hello if electrical switches stopped
scaling for free we'll have an increase
in the cost and I'll explain the shape
of this curve in a couple of slides from
now what's really worrying is the timing
of this because this is expected to
happen around the same time where the
cloud traffic not only continues to grow
but it's pace actually picks up because
of custom hardware FPGAs GPUs because of
new scenarios like large-scale learning
which means that we'll be generating and
consuming a lot more data and doing it
in a power efficient fashion so this is
a big problem for us and one of the
things or one of the benefits of working
at a place like Microsoft Research is
that we always think of mediums term
strategic solutions and long term
disruptive solutions and I wanted to
give you a sense of those sort of
examples of those solutions in the
context of this problem over the next
few slides so you understand a solution
let's look inside the problem for a
second so if you look at a switch inside
the switch we have a switching ASIC that
sits on a substrate or a package
connected by BGA connectors or i/o pins
a PCB trace and an optical transceiver
that goes from the bits of the
electronic an domains to optical domain
so something tiny like this now it is
the speed and the density of the i/o
pins that causing the problem because
it's harder and harder to scale and so
the obvious thing to do is that well why
don't we move the optics closer to the
switching ASIC which means that you get
rid of this bottleneck resource and the
switches are easier to scale now this is
something that's been discussed a lot in
the optics community and silicon
photonics space lots of names to it we
are calling it in package optics it's
essentially what the switch would look
like two generations from now is
you'd have a switching ASIC it would be
surrounded by chip 'lets comprising
electrical components so all the drivers
and all the analog components and then
the optical chip le'ts and what this
would do is it would take the data being
generated by the ASIC and modulate light
which is then sent tens or hundreds of
meters now in this case the triplet is
made in silicon because the field
reasons to reduce costs and to make it
amenable to integration with the CMOS
racing and what we've started doing is
actually designing our own chips so this
is a silicon based chip are designed at
a lab hi sky here and he's our so he's a
chief designer who makes these chips for
us that are being fabricated at external
foundries now one of the key technical
challenges here is that well to do
optical networking you need light and
it's hard to generate light in silicon
it's a fundamental problem it's an
indirect bandgap material so what we now
need to do is need to have disaggregated
transceivers because in a standard
transceiver the laser and the modulator
is in the same package whereas in this
case we need a separate light source in
this case which happens to be shared
across all the chip plates and this is
cool because it means that we can have a
better light source we can actually cool
it better and I think that is going to
tell us tell you about more about some
of the implications of this
architectural chain now this is
typically made in a material like indium
phosphide and again we've started
designing our own chips and I think this
is animation that will show you the
different layers of the chip it
comprises lasers waveguides no other
components
I think it's a few millimeters by
philometor sky so 12 minute does by 12
millimeters and that's going to be
shared across the entire switch now this
is an example of a medium-term solution
and I want to step back and talk about
the implications of this for the overall
cloud Network cost so historically cost
has been neutral we're seeing signs of
disturbances but if we are able to
deliver on this in package of
solution we'd be able to extend the cost
neutrality of switches for the next five
or six years which is great it because
it means are the world's not ending but
at some point we'll run into the actual
physical constraints on the number of
fibers that we can align at the edge of
the switching ASIC which means that
we'll have to have complex solutions and
an increase in overall extra cost and at
some point we run into the actual seam
of scaling limit whereby you cannot put
more transistors onto the switching
Idzik which means that we'll have
multiple Asics on the same die inside
each pack inside each switch which in
turn means an increase in complexity and
an increase in cost for every network
generation thereafter and that's the
nightmare scenario for us and that's
where we really really come in the long
term opportunity for optics of photonics
so what we really want to do is actually
look at these topologies and instead of
using electrical package switches
replace them with optical circuits which
is something that's been thought a lot
about in the optics community and in the
network community now one of the
advantages of moving away from CMOS
components is that you can develop
technologies that have a much higher
radix and you can have a much flatter
topology this means that we can offer
better performance per dollar because
there are fewer transceivers and fewer
switches in the network we can because
there's no buffering inside the network
we can offer very low and very
predictable agency and that
predictability is really important for
the kinds of application scenarios that
we expect to develop in the cloud over
the next few years and finally because
we don't have dependency on CMOS this
can actually be a long lasting solution
so this is actually motivated us over
the past couple of years as a team to
develop a research prototype that shows
the basic feasibility of achieving a
very fast optical switching nanoseconds
switching so that we can match the
performance of electrical packet
switches so stuff that's not done a lot
in the optics community but this is now
taking of building a real system out of
it now I do want to point out that there
is a
big difference in a circuit-switched
architecture and a packet-switched
architecture and so there's a long long
way to go to take this from up research
through try with a bunch of wires back
in Cambridge do something that can
connect an actual data center and run
real applications so just want to check
the you know keep the expectations in
check but the IPO technology gives us
the space the four to five years needed
to do that so I want to change tack now
quickly and move outside the data center
and give you another example of this
sort of hardware software network optics
Co design so about five years ago we
used to build megaria central facilities
a few hundred thousand servers big LAN
lots of power but increasingly we are
finding it hard to find the land and the
power and space for such mega facilities
so over the past couple of years we
moved to the regional architecture where
we have many medium sized data centers
about hundred thousand servers in the
same metro region so 80 kilometers
connected by a regional hub now let's
think about the implications of this for
the unlined network architecture so in a
traditional mega datacenter we have the
standard cross topology in this case I'm
showing four levels in all our data
centers we use optical cables outside
the rack which means that every switch
port needs that transceiver that are
shown earlier to do the opto electronic
conversion and this is a great
transceiver so transmits over a single
wavelength and then we do transmission
over the long haul so when you're going
thousands of kilometres we need a
colored transceiver which is massive
power-hungry and you know rather heavy
so I can't keep this too long on the
other hand then you move to the regional
architecture what happens is that well
yes you are essentially taking this big
block and doing smaller chunks but your
regional links the one in the red is
actually 80 kilometers so what this
means is that yes we can use great
transceivers inside the data centers but
now we have to use colored power it's
expensive hungry transceivers both on
the van on the
link's and this is a nightmare if you
were to do this for power and cost and
space and all these reasons so what the
azure networking team did is they
actually went out and design their own
transceivers that are customized for the
regional environment this is a correct
transceiver that can operate over 80
kilometers you can see it's exactly the
same form factor of the great
transceiver that we use inside the data
center and essentially the trick is to
customize the DSP to customize the feck
for the particular scenario of interest
if the lights not going tens of
thousands of kilometers why would we do
chromatic dispersion for that distance
so those are the kinds of designing for
our scenarios that led to this
innovation and this was core design both
inside the company and working within
Phi who manufactures these transceivers
and these are being deployed in our data
centers over the past year so the reason
I chose these two examples is to give
you a sense of our thinking innovation
are by combining optics with networking
distributed systems architecture and
hardware and we genuinely believe that
to develop the next generation of cloud
infrastructure we will have to innovate
across the stack and we can do this
because that as a cloud operator we own
and operate the entire stack as I showed
you we are developing our own custom
chips we are building optical components
we have designed and are deploying our
own transceivers and our own switches
and as you'll hear we already have our
NICs so we can deploy things on the
stack on the neck or the servers
themselves which allows us to innovate
across the stack and that's something
that we're doing both in our work but
also in all our collaborations with a
committee collaborators for example the
work that we're doing with Dan and many
of you in this room so that's the
message I wanted to get across thank you
for your time I think I'm running out of
time so thanks
[Applause]
yeah whoa do we have time for a question
yeah maybe so
real fast um you didn't say anything
about efficient use of the optical
network but even with 100 megabits 100
gigabit right now we're seeing the
people doing small writes and not many
of the data lanes on on this sort of
wide data path are really occupied so
you've got you know say it's a 10 day
two-lane sixty-six bits each and you've
got one byte of good data there yeah
maybe 60 bytes of headers and the rest
is just empty what can be done at that
layer that's a very good question
I mean you were too short answers to
that question you can apply that
question in the want van scenario where
efficiency is very important and you
really need to think about
software-defined primitives to achieve
that I think your question is more in
the intra DC context and one of the
interesting things about the inter DC
context is that things like the 60 right
header of the 40 byte header come from
scenarios if we are limited to legacy
protocols if we control things like the
NIC and the underlying network in many
customized scenarios like our DMA
clusters I would argue we should just go
to customized protocols that reduce a
lot of this already yeah yeah I
completely agree I think in that sense
you really need a decoupling of the data
pane and the control plane would which
allow you to make those changes yes
and company take me on that front do we
have one question maybe that's bringing
the guys oh okay yeah all right thank
you - again thank
next speaker is Tom Anderson I believe
most of you already know him he is a
short description our common sense the
chair in a poll and school for computer
science engineering at the UW his
research interests span all aspects of
building practical robust and efficient
computer systems so he is a member of
National Academy of Engineering and the
window of multiple Lifetime Achievement
Awards great and I think actually this
will be this great counterpoint I think
there are I'm actually at at essence and
operating systems person and many of the
things that have been driving our
research over time is just this
recognition that we are in the cloud
setting spending or particularly for
really key applications spending huge
amounts of time just doing these
repetitive operations in the operating
system and what's clear about the
hardware technology trends are that
everything that can be re-implemented
everything that's bits of high-capacity
the things that you're doing all the
time are going to be re-implemented
hardware just you can't afford to do
just general-purpose processing for
things that you're doing many many times
you can see this with TP use but you're
also going to see this on networking and
for operating systems so essentially the
argument that I'm going to try to make
here what we've been looking at is is on
the protocol stack but but more broadly
I think one could ask this question more
generally about operating systems in
general so if you look at how I'm gonna
come down from application side rather
than up from what we can do in hardware
so one of the things that's really
characteristic of these applications is
of the applications people actually run
in data centers is that large amounts of
a very fine grained communication partly
just because as you start to spread
applications out over more and more
nodes because you need more and more
nodes because Dennard scaling isn't
doing it for you now your communication
granularity goes down and kind of
interesting data set that
somebody in the sitcom community
collected all of the day all of the are
PCs inside of the Google Data Center
over a period of time that the that the
median size of that was only 300 bytes
so generally you're doing single packet
transfers between nodes you still want
the semantics of TCP so that is reliable
in order delivery
it's many-to-many so what you addicted
it's like the applications that this
drives for key value stores databases
distributed analytics and that you're
pushing performance limits on those and
then scaling up as you go so the
question is how you can deal with this
so on the on the software processing
side Linux even if you kind of ignore
the VM layer because you're gonna say
catapult will take care of that for you
the on the VM side are on the TCP side
you're spending huge amounts of time
doing just regular processing just you
know if you're trying to do through
Linux you know about three and a half
microseconds per packet and then single
core performance is not gonna it's not
gonna bail you out so you could try to
paralyze this that has try to run many
many connections over many many cores
but potentially it's gonna just end up
burning lots of power and and spending a
lot of effort a lot of costs and time
doing things that you don't really need
to do so there are a lot to propose
solutions to this probably everybody in
the room would like no many of these so
one of them is Karl bypass so DP 2k or
things like that it the challenge though
is that what you want is something
that's going to give you a policy
enforcement that is if you're in a
multi-tenant data center you also need
to worry about well what are these
applications actually doing and can you
trust them is is it going to be the case
that they're gonna obey congestion
control your behavior of your network is
going to depend on n host behavior so
you need something that's gonna give you
policy enforcement some people are
deploying smart necks or NIC CPU arrays
and I should say actually there's some
really nice paper from MSR that Sombra
is possibly gonna start but I'm not sure
that actually goes through essentially a
lot of the same arguments and that
appeared at the last n STI 18 and
actually makes all the same arguments
that we would make so if you do if you
try to put on your neck
essentially cpu arrays the challenge for
that is there is this complicated thing
as you scale out the number of CPUs are
doing your TCP processing that you have
this complex assignment problem of that
to the CPU array and limited per flow
performance that is if you're you
potentially want really high bandwidth
for a given individual flow and it's
also relatively expensive to go build
those our DMA is the one that the
research community is spending most of
their time on in fact most of the stuff
that I'm gonna talk about here is
essentially trying to understand how you
would build a more flexible our DMA
engine Rema the api is fine for some
things but certainly for these kind of
small scale single packet RPC
communication as a protocol rotate
writing or reading from a memory isn't
necessarily the natural thing that you
would do if you wanted to build a really
fast RPC system and then the hardware
for our DMA actually bundles not so well
with congestion control protocols that
you would actually want to use in
practice and so some people had also
done TCP offload engines be an example
you need there's gonna be an argument
that are gonna make towards protocol
agility so ultimately if they can't
integrate over that whole set I think
what you want is the traditional
operating system functionality that is
the feature set of operating systems
which is multi-tenant isolation the
ability to say that the behavior of
applications doesn't affect other
applications and at the same time
hardware assists that is some way of
doing a flexible reconfigurable
architecture so that you could then
change your protocols as you need them
do you policy compliance as you want
scale up connections to really large
numbers of connections cpu efficiency in
the common case and performance
efficiency so essentially you would
think of you want the flexibility side
to be able to do whatever you want
and at this and the other side be able
to handle the stuff at the speeds that
you want to handle them without having
to do a huge amount and I'm gonna make
this argument Oh independently of the
FPGA vs VLSI argument I Microsoft has
its own perspective on this which is
FPGA so the feature but in some ways the
argument I'm going to make here is gonna
be independent of that so you can think
of this hardware assist at multiple
levels so one layer and the key note
talked about some of this extent which
Microsoft has already deployed widely
demonstrated this if you're only asking
it but the packet processing at the VM
layer that is creating a virtual network
that the that makes the virtual machine
look like oh okay I've got my own little
land here that I'm gonna be able to
communicate with that set of work is
pretty regular and actually a pretty
damaged demonstrable that you can move
that unto Hardware what I'm gonna end up
talking about is a harder problem which
is okay now once you've gotten these
packets to the virtual machine the
virtual machines now spending almost all
of its time doing TCP packet processing
in the in the virtual machine the guest
operating system so that's inefficient
from the customer perspective it's like
why was i burning all those cpu time for
that so can you take and try to do
hardware acceleration there it's
flexible hardware acceleration inside
the VM so how you teach me packet
processing in hardware and then there
you could ask the similar question about
the application level processing so
you're handing this off to an
application it's also doing essentially
layer seven packet processing how do you
want to try to optimize that this whole
set of things can actually be handled in
foot in this thing that I'm gonna talk
called flex NIC but it's just a model
for how you would do the programming for
it and then I'm also going to talk a
little bit about how you could do this
flexibility at network switches and in
general this where this is going to tie
in with the optical side is where you do
have congestion that is where you have
large amounts of communication coming in
generally at the at the top of rack
switch or whatever you are going to need
to be able to do something on the level
of trying to do resource allocation in
some fashion light largely and
kind of programmable space okay the
overarching lesson here is going to be
that common case packet handling is
systolic which is to say that individual
packet the steps that you're taking to
do packet processing is regular risible
and that can be pipelined not just
packet to packet but even within a
packet that you can do kind of regular
communication and as a consequence of
that that you can you will end up being
able to do large amounts of sorry high
bandwidth operations even on a single
flow because you're pipelining
individual individual stages of
computation and and I'll come back to
this point that I made earlier which is
that the anything that can be
regularized and you're spending a lot of
time on will eventually be building the
hardware it's just how the economics of
data center is going to work so now the
question is how how how you can go about
this and this will happen both on Nick's
n switches okay so the programming model
we started with is is usually
reconfigurable multi stage pipelines
were not the only people working in the
space you take this packet stream coming
in you have a programmable parser that
that goes through some number of stages
of computation the these computational
stages are protocol agnostic you can run
essentially about a terabit per second
in a single pipeline the Barefoot's
demonstrated that so from a NIC
perspective that is from an end host
perspective that's pretty good that'll
carry you pretty far and it has and the
idea is going to have predictable
performance the stages all executed in
parallel you can think of essentially
each successive packet it goes through
the stage in in the sequence as a
consequence you know from a single flow
perspective you're still processing
everything in order as opposed to
spreading it out over multiple pipelines
or multiple CPUs which we might be doing
in a smart NIC operation then you're
having to make sure that all of the
packets for a given flow go through the
same sequence are on the same processor
just for kind of state management or
ordering constraints okay so what are
these match action systems do you can
think of them kind of the simple simple
cases that they can steer packets they
can initiate D
a trigger replies or whatever they're
just doing some kind of simple oh this
is an application that's that's trying
to write on a particular port then what
I should do with this is to hash it to a
particular core and then DMA to a - to a
queue or something like that that
because their regular against is stuff
in a systolic model you don't want loops
there's no complicated arithmetic you
have to be careful about what you're
doing with state you can't have an
arbitrary number of stages it's not
programming the way we would normally
think of it rather your programming kind
of for hardware and so we built kind of
designed a part of this from a kind of
NIC perspective how you would actually
make this work is you actually for the
NIC actually has multiple pipelines
coming in so it has data coming in for
received data that is you're having to
do some set of pipeline stages for
packets that are arriving from the
network
similarly the host itself is also
delivering packets into the NIC
and so we have some pipeline for
handling that there's a transmit
pipeline to actually send data out
there's also a pipeline to try to do
essentially programmable NIC behavior
you can kind of imagine if you were to
try to decompose what happens on an RDM
a packet if you're coming like if that
was your protocol that you were trying
to implement what happens on an eidm a
packet is that you're essentially de-mux
your you're parsing the packet and then
d muxing on an element of the packet to
tell the dma engine to do a particular
operation that that step is something
that's pretty taught that's pretty
similar to what a TCP packet does when
you arrive like okay I'm gonna get this
packet in and I want to decide which
queue this is going to go into based on
the port number and then based on that
I'm gonna and maybe this the
sequence number in the packet and then
that's going to tell me where to go from
there so what this then allows me to do
is to do this transform these packets
efficiently and software DMA directly in
and out of application data structure so
it looks like it's just already you know
has all the same benefits that already
you may have and then send
acknowledgments out on the neck but
potentially you can implement
TCB with it so if you look at what tcp
is doing it's got a lot going on right
you're opening because in connections
you've got locking on socket API you've
got IP routing our firewalls like
congestion control like very complicated
connection state often in the kernel if
you look at the kernel code you're doing
multiple steps each in you're chasing
data structures you're doing pointer
chasing a lot of it's like oh okay how
is this going to end up working in this
kind of systolic model and the model
we've taken is one that would take and
essentially split out the operating
system code into kind of a fast path
that's regular izybelle and then a slow
path for everything that's not regular
risible
and then hopefully take oh okay the slow
path just handles offline so you can
think essentially of the fast path doing
all of the normal operations you would
do on every data on every data packet
generating data segments applying rate
limits and so forth collecting
congestion statistics all of this and
ending up running on the NIC itself and
then the slow path running in the kernel
that handles essentially all the other
kind of essentially connection or
control plane operations and then the
application it's up doing some
additional amount of work one of the
aspects of this is say that you're
splitting up congestion control in a way
that splits the work so that instead of
thinking that you're doing can just
control every packet you can think that
you're doing it on it on a kind of
roundtrip basis so collecting
information on the data path and then
using it on a kind of background basis
to enforce control and but that's
actually sufficient for implementing the
protocols that we have so this is a kind
of performance graph we all end up
leaving here which is essentially you
know how well this can do the the yellow
this is lint this is Linux here scaling
up to sixteen core is not very well and
then a software implementation of what
I've just described which actually does
enforce congestion control compared to a
software version of of just a DDP a TCP
version that doesn't enforce congestion
for all
they actually do reasonably well and
then a kind of hardware version is that
line over there all of this is actually
just emulated rather than other I'll
just take just briefly talk about you
can actually think about a bunch of
these issues also happening inside of
the network itself so switches
themselves can also be programmable and
you could ask this question of what can
we do inside of the network using
reprogrammable hardware to do different
things and one of the things that we've
been looking at is to do essentially
fair approximate fair queuing so fair
queuing is one of these things that have
is a kind of long standing maybe 30 40
years ago I'm actually sure exactly when
it was 30 30 years ago okay so I think
we like dated from almost before I
graduated from grad school so that's
like how long ago it was but the idea is
that you get isolation that has predict
more predictable behavior out of your
network if you're able to say that if
you're queueing discipline and how you
handle packets inside of the network
base fair queuing the challenge for it
is that it's really difficult to
implement these things in a in any kind
of fashion that this is just an
animation of what happens as you go
about do they do this in order to get
fair queuing to work and I'll just go
forward for this the different pieces
you need to have a sorted packet buffer
you need to store an update per flow
counters you need to track a global
state that updates on every packet and
all of that ends up like okay how are
you gonna end up implementing that at
multi gigabit speeds we were talking
about trying to implement it at many
cake events and so the argument is that
you could potentially use this kind of a
reconfigurable match action model to
simulate fair queuing or approximate for
queuing and I'm not gonna actually do
the example here but but I'll just skip
by it but the idea is basically to use
multiple queues to try to approximate
the behavior store approximate per flow
counters in tables and so forth so
there's a lot of kind of research that
people are doing in terms of trying to
understand what you can do with
reprogrammable switches and that outcome
this ends up being so this table here
this is actually flow size on the on the
x-axis and then a normalized completion
time on the y-axis so small is better
and then AF Q which is the blue line so
as you get bigger flows than of course
it takes longer to complete but but one
of the things that you end up seeing is
even for things like DCT CP which is
kind of the best-known congestion
control protocol for data centers you
can do better as a consequence of having
more intelligence happening inside of
the switch okay and I'll just leave it
there right Thank You Vince so you
talked about TCP so totally Kona bypass
technique oh it is too isolating the
kernel stack using the hardware so the
enforcement you can think of as the
equivalent of virtual I think that the
partly the best analogy for this is
there was a period about 40 or 50 years
ago where we decided that what we needed
to do for multi programming was to have
virtual memory hardware and there was a
period where people didn't know what
that virtual memory Hardware looked like
like what exactly were the abstractions
what were you gonna what we ended up
with what was this notion of having
essentially table-driven enforcement
mechanism that's controlled by the
operating system kernel that model is
essentially the one that we're moving
towards which is we're trying to come up
with some new set of constraints some
new model for how operating systems are
going to interact with networks that
going to be okay those control planes
operating in the kernel that's that's
that's the enforcement mechanism an
applications perspective and then
everything everything else the app with
the
application actually does itself is all
done at full speed and so what VM
hardware does essentially is to say look
in the normal case you're executing at
the full speed of the hardware even
though I'm providing this kind of
protection layer in with some hardware
system and the question that we're
ending up trying to figure out is what
is that hardware assist that you need to
be able to implement this at full speed
sorry did you did you I have I have the
microphone yeah so I'll ask my question
anyway so a lot of dialogue about our
DMA centers on use of resources that are
really living in the OS such as the the
page table entries and the actually the
specific DMA mappings and then the DMA
permissions records which are well
tables but then this struts to exceed
the amount of SRAM available and most of
these NICs don't have time to go off to
DRAM on an average packet um do you have
an opinion on all that and where's that
trending yeah so uh I think some growth
that's like if you wanted to start
coming up there was a really nice
again.this NS di paper of looking at how
they map catapult they they have a
two-level connection state model where
the SRAM is for the active connections
and then they have a dram backup for for
other ones I think once you start to
think that your operating system is
managing hundreds of thousands of
packets you're needing to do some kind
of two-stage model for it so I think
that also is a really interesting
question of well if everybody is
actively using say tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of packets of
connections simultaneously then does
this kind of cash in model work and how
do you make that work now the upside is
that even if you have to fetch your data
in from a deep into dierent your
connection state in from DRAM to do some
work it's still as long as it's
relatively compact the only amount of
the thing that you might be doing over
time would be some regular amount of
operation that the amount of time that a
connection is actually actively using
nick is gonna be relatively small so the
the only am number of active connections
you might be doing inside the neck at
any point in time I'd might not be large
there are also large amounts of like
just regular protocol issues that come
from running trying to run large numbers
of connection simultaneously like TCP is
just basically broken for once you get
above a thousand connections we we ran a
really simple test that just doing
simple RBC's between two nodes with a
thousand connections and Linux will
actually literally starve connections
like just like okay is that the best we
can do what you're proposing is flex
next looks a lot like before are you
trying to use the same programming
strats traction of p4 at the host site
so you can think of it as very similar
to p4 I think the difference is p4
doesn't really have a model for how to
program DMA and so we added essentially
it's people were plus the kind of DMA
programming okay okay let's thank Tom
again the next speaker is a brahma
monkey she's a technic technical lead in
agile networking working in the area of
authority networking so Microsoft she
has primary work on network offloading
technologies especially in the area of
network virtualization such as virtual
machine queue single route IRS IOT and
general generic flow table offroading
thank you hi like he said my name is sim
brahma i'm a tech lead in agile
networking I specifically work in the
host networking group and for the last
couple of years what we've been working
on is to offload the software stack that
we have in the as your host or to an
FPGA smart NIC and deploying this
entirely in our Azure data centers and
seeing great benefits out of it in
performance and latency throughput per
packets packets per second etc so I'll
go into some of the details about how we
went about implementing this so the
agenda for might
we'll be a little bit about the edge of
background how the problems that we have
in scale and the SDN stack the way it's
implemented today in the software stack
and what are some of the challenges we
face around that and in packet
processing at a per packet level in the
host and we'll also talk about what
other considerations we employed to
determine that FPGA smart NIC is the
right choice for us to go forward and
then I'll go into some of the details of
or the architecture and the design of
the smart NIC
and then we have a lot of lessons
learned because this is pretty much the
first time where we are deploying at
such a scale software hardware project
coexistence and there you know deploying
hardware at such a scale to be able to
debug it monitor it have alerts and at
an agile way very which is like our you
know a cornerstone of azure and
networking so this is the generic slide
that we use for the azure services so we
have at the bottom most layer the
infrastructure service which includes
our storage compute networking etc and
on top of it we have the data services
and and providing the app services like
as your ML Analytics etc so azure and
networking has come a long way since it
was first deployed from in terms of
compute we have started from like 10k or
100k of VMs and now we are at millions
of virtual machines and as your storage
has seen the same rate of growth as well
as the networking where we are seeing
from terabytes of data to petabytes
today so this is a general marketing
slide that we use and we see at what
rate the azure is growing on a day to
day basis literally we have to have
support for all the Linux Williams
because most of the virtual machines
that are out there are Linux VMs and we
see a great growth in terms of the
deployment onboarding of new customers
and the different kind of features and
requirements that we have in terms of
Azure and networking specifically as
well so that would kind of show us like
the
that we may need to maintain because a
lot of the features that we add our
customer driven either through issues
that they face or the new features that
they need to move from their current
model on Prem Network to the azure
network
so other ways to think about scale so V
it's not just about deploying a this
service or deploying a feature it's
about how do we handle failures how do
we detect monitor and it's a continuous
feedback loop that we need to be in and
believe me I
we often get our on-call rotations and
it's not pretty to live through a
one-week of an on-call rotation because
if you don't have a backup of knowing
how to automate this detection of heart
failures like switch link node failures
you know the crashing of any software
components in the nodes etc we need at
such a large scale it's impossible to do
I mean literally impossible to do
manually or even not having a super
sophisticated automated solution for
that so so we have and another customer
goal would be to actually one is
detection of these failures and
mitigation of it so most likely we would
prefer to know about an issue before a
customer even notices it so we need to
have the automation in place to detect
these conditions that are going on some
hard failures and be able to mitigate it
which would be like a service healed the
virtual machine to a different node or
in our case for example switch back from
let's say if the hardware is misbehaving
switch back to the software path etc and
then we always have the problem of soft
failures which are not obvious obviously
if the link is down between two switches
it's easy to detect easy to fix but if
there are soft failures that we see very
often is like one in like 100 packets is
getting corrupted by one extra byte or
something like that and though sometimes
I've seen even in practice those go
unnoticed until a for example in our
case when we offloaded this flow to an
FPGA the FPGA was adding an extra 32
bytes at the end of the packet and that
went unnoticed until some TLS type of
checksum was happening and then the
the customer endpoint they would see an
effect of this so how do we detect these
kind of failures and lot of issues that
we see are in latency so generally
everything is working fine occasionally
the latency peaks at 50 milliseconds or
something like that in a TC paying type
of operation so how do we detect that
how do we monitor that at that scale
that's also very important so I think
again like I'm stressing the automation
is the key for all this the other thing
is the is customers they are highly
intolerant to any virtual machine
downtime or any networking downtime so
whenever we have to service any of our
components and we have a lot of
components including in the hosts in the
virtual machine in the host and now in
the hardware etc the serviceability is
the key we cannot afford to bring down
the host we cannot reboot so we try to
update all our components reboot Leslie
except for the OS which also we try to
do it in such a fashion that the
downtime is extremely less any
networking components being updated or
being serviced need to guarantee that we
do not see a network outage to the
virtual machine and we try our best to
actually keep the TCP connections alive
so that's the goal of it basically the
VM should not really be able to see a
TCP connection drop so the key to this
is performance all the everything is
measured at like four to five nines and
on our customer basis which includes the
performance the network performance the
host performance the availability the VM
availability whether the they should not
suffer any kind of down time and the
serviceability of all our components so
how do we achieve Sdn in Azure so today
what we do is what we call is the host
Sdn so our data plane runs in the host
we have our distributed controllers that
are running across the regions so for
example the SLB has a regional SLB
manager for any v-net programming there
is an regional network manager etc that
is per region and we have controllers
running in each of the hosts so any of
the configuration that comes along for
from the management plane which is using
the REST API like a portal or
CLI however the deployment occurs for
the virtual machine that comes to the
regional network manager eventually and
those policies are programmed to a per
host level and and the so the controller
on the host programs our virtual switch
that runs in the host and the data plane
in the virtual switch is which applies
the policies so obviously then you have
this data plane needs to apply the flow
policy to millions of VMs and that's
only achievable because we are handling
it at the host level for whatever number
of VMs that are running on the host so
this is a diagram of our software stack
this runs in each of the hosts so we
have the virtual machines hosted on the
azure node or the host as we call it
so before hardware acceleration what is
presented to the virtual machine is a
synthetic NIC or a software NIC any
packet that needs to come in and out of
the VM is always going through the
software stack in the VM that goes
through the hypervisor to the host and
in the host we have what we call as a VM
switch which is a layer to switch which
basically is really a delivery mechanism
in and out of the VM and all the
policies that are told that get applied
to the core the controllers the
controller programs using a vfp api
which is a simple match action and match
action table API so that the
controller's program the vfp with that
information so like I said there could
be different kinds of controllers like
something for load balancing something
for a V net customer address to the
provider address mapping
ackles metering etcetera so each of the
controllers can program their own rules
and those go into different layers of
vfp and they're independent of each
other so if you were to add a new
feature we could have a new layer and
none of the other controllers would have
to change any of their policy
so in vfp what would happen is so let's
take an example of a packet being
transmitted from the VM that would land
from the VM over what we call as a
virtual machine bus to the host from the
hypervisor and in the host when it hits
the VM switch VFP is bill
as an extension to vm switch so
originally when we started as you're all
of the policy enforcement was done as
part of vm switch and then due to
different constraints because you will
have the vm switch update is a requires
a reboot etc so we went with this model
of having a pluggable virtual filtering
platform within vm switch so every
packet that vm switch sees in inbound
and outbound path is routed through VF p
and VF p is the one that is the brains
of the host Sdn on the host so it
applies all the policies it goes through
the layers for example on an outbound
packet it would go through the a
K'Ehleyr modify the packet based on the
configuration go to the V net layer
modify the that packet let's say map the
CA to the PA and this might also need
some communication to the regional
control plane for example you might not
have the mapping of this destination VM
you might need to wait for that
configuration to come back and then
apply that change to that packet and
then go to the SLP layer so any whip to
dip mapping would occur there so this
processing allows us to do multiple
layers independent of different kind of
controllers programming it then we go
one step further than this that once
this packet goes through it if you see a
connection setup packet like in the case
of TCP it being the syn packet you know
that this is a packet and these are the
flow the flow ID for this packet and the
end result is always going to be the
same so Akal v-net SLP the NAT layer
combine it and what is the final action
that is called as a transposition we can
save that information so that you don't
have to go to the individual layers
after the connection setup is done so we
call this technology called as a unified
flow which is actually the basis for our
offloading to the accelerated NICs
yeah so basically so what so this again
explains how we would go through the
layering occur both in the inbound and
outbound so the vfp is also the
forwarder so once it does the outbound
processing for a packet it forwards the
packet determines the target and then
does the inbound processing based on the
rule set up for that port so the target
could either be another VM on the same
host for example if they were to be Ruby
to VM and we are seeing more of this in
particular requirements or it could be
another VM on a V net in as you're
within the region or another region or
it could be some internet endpoint so it
doesn't matter basically the vfp is just
doing a per port policy application on
inbound and outbound so this just shows
you the flow of a packet so for example
the Ackles would be applied their
different action is specified for that
layer for example drop certain packets
with 10.4 16 address etc and then the
action at the load balancer layer and
then the v-net mapping would occur at
the end layer so what do we see as a
challenge us in this right this works
fine at 1 G at 10 G it works fine but
what do we see as challenges as the the
networking speed increases there are
more and more packets being generated
but there's not enough CPU to handle
this load so we and what are the options
for us so we would prefer to offload
this to hardware but when we offload it
to Hardware using Asics you are having a
one or two years of cycle to update the
Asics it might not be sufficient what
are the features available in the Asics
etcetera so we have to go with we
decided to look at FPGAs to solve this
problem so what we have is today we
still have the the ASIC NIC that
provides the access to the virtual
machine there is a technology called
single route I of virtualization which
allows the virtual functions of PC a
virtual function to be exposed to the VM
so the packets from the VM can directly
access the network to and from it but if
he did that then it would be bypassing
the host and there would be nobody
applying the policies so we go with this
bump in the wire model that the delivery
of the packets and reception of the
packets from the VM still occurs on the
virtual function and the existing NIC
and any of the offloads that the NIC can
provide for example receives scaling
like CPU steering tasks off loads like
checksum etcetera or lots of offload
that can still occur at that NIC
but the policy application on a per
packet basis occurs on an FPGA that's
programmed by our VFP
and we use this API called the GFT api
which converts the unified flow that we
talked about in the vfp to the to the to
the to the settings basically what the
FPGA understands and these are some of
the measurements that we got from
running regular you know open source
tools like iperf and soft path and you
see I'll just go quickly over this is
like you see the compute D series gets
up to 25 G and we see improvements in
the latency especially because we have
SRV totally bypassed the whole stack so
we see you know per packet per second
improvement and then you obviously also
reduce jitter because you don't have any
software issues of getting D scheduled
by hypervisor to run vm processing etc
so this gives us more course for the vm
processing or floats or the network to
the hardware and then since the vm can
get near native performance we can also
include other workloads that needed that
kind of performance so this is an
example of what on the left side you
have how the packets transmission and
reception looks like in the case where
it's being processed by the software so
anything coming out of the vm goes to
the virtual switch does the processing
then goes out of the physical layer but
in the case of accelerated networking it
just goes to the network card and
directly out of the Tod and beyond so
this is an example of how the gft
actually does the processing so like I
said the controller's program vfp asked
today there's no change over there VFP
still needs to be there in the path of
what we call as exception packets which
is the connection set of packets and for
TCP it is syn syn ack packets for you
repeats the first packet that we see so
we are right now offloading just TCP and
UDP and potentially we would do our DMA
flows as well so like I said the unified
flow gets created in the vfp when it
does receive the first packet so it goes
through the slow path processing in
across each layers generates this
unified flow which is this is a flow and
this is the action and that is what it
configures to the GF T so when g FD r is
our in GF T is the engine running inside
the FPGA smartening so when FPGA
receives this packet from the VM let's
say an outbound packet it goes through
its stable there's a multi
a layer hash table lookup so like he was
saying on the SRAM and then we have an
l1 cache and you don't find the packet
go to the DRAM look up look up that and
if you don't find that packet or a flow
for that particular packet that's tagged
as an exception packet and in sent to
this whole stack for VfB to process and
if it does find the packet which is when
VFP offloads this flow then it does the
transformation itself bypasses the stack
and sends it out on the tour similarly
if you receive a packet the same
mechanism happens but when it will
indicate the packet to the ASIC NIC
which is using the SR io v and directly
indicating the packet to VM again we
bypass the host and off the key thing
for this is serviceability so
serviceability is a key is because we
need to be able to update any of the
components without any kind of down time
for the VM because we have to so I have
just one minute so I'll quickly go over
some of the lessons we learnt in this
area as well so one of that is basically
if the VM cannot suffer downtime then we
need to have a failover simple failover
from the hardware to the software path
when any of the key components are being
serviced and so that was one of the key
things that we did as part of the
initial design because we also need a
service because the whole idea of using
FPGA is to be innovate as fast as we can
which means like we our goal is to
service the entire stack every month in
in a sprint fashion right so some of the
lessons that we learned is I would say
the most important is monitoring is
really the key it's not in my bullet
points here but monitoring is the key
because at this scale when you see in
generally in hardware we tend to think
that okay you need to get a repro all
that's not going to happen right like
customers facing this issue you got to
figure it out so we need to have as much
as monitoring alerts and notifications
that we can have the failure rate has
remained quite low and we have some
alerts for that like you know DRAM
failing over the power over some time or
some of the parts that like oscillators
and stuff like that failing so we're
kind of monitoring that like what the
thing is for that and I think another
thing is like it's a mindset change as
well because to work in the coexist in
fashion between
we're engineers and software engineers
to build a team around that that had
like initial challenges to understand
each other etc and that is an iterative
problem that you to solve and the
biggest like benefit that I saw of this
one on first hand is basically when we
have a new Sdn feature that we want to
implement in the software earlier when
we started off the software existed and
we figure out how to offload the stuff
to hardware so that's the way we were
thinking but now when we whenever we are
doing a software feature we say okay how
is hardware able to support it because
we do have hardware limitations in terms
of tables etcetera so that is also
another like a mind shift that we see
while doing this entire project so
that's it any questions or I don't have
time the question here yeah I had a
quick question about migration it seemed
like there's a lot of dependency on the
hardware and whatnot so like live
migration yes yes so we do take that
into account and that does mean at this
point of time to offload to upload the
flows from the hardware to the software
because we need to save the state of the
VM as it is and then migrated out so we
will remove the hardware offloads at
that point of time save the state move
it and then re-enable the hardware
offload set in the destination yeah
do you anticipate there to be any
scalability limits with FPGAs as we
scale to even faster and host networking
stay for the gigabits per second maybe
even 800 gigabits per second yeah we do
see that actually at this point of time
the bottleneck is the host because we
still have to do the first packet
processing in the host
so once the offloads have been offloaded
to the hardware it is still able to
scale at that level but we make
continuous improvements for example you
have the you also have a memory
constraint which is also a bottleneck in
that thing right because you have
multiple flows you started out with a
single full size VM and then you go down
to having multiple flows there is a
limit at the end of it and if any packet
has to get processed in the host because
of Hardware limits that is a problem
that we have to look at either
yes I guess a following question um do
programmable ASIC switches like the
barefoot switches have the capability to
handle all the layers here and also hit
the cost point as an alternative one
that's and what scale up switch is like
the barefoot switches the programmable
ASIC switches have the capabilities to
handle this as they scale up in capacity
to I I'm not aware but the one thing is
we are doing all this in the host so
that is something that we have to keep
in mind like we have to support the
hosts Sdn because that's where we try to
do all the policy enforcement
[Applause]